[Music]
and where is yasser
did he arrive
oh you finally showed up
closing ceremony of the 2021 sinfield
cup we had a fantastic
tournament
players really regaled us with their
incredible play their fighting spirit
their tenacity and brilliant moves
uh we want to thank shannon bailey for
hosting us here the world chess hall of
fame a beautiful space
that always
brings about kind of
amazing memories of chess
recognizing the accomplishments of many
greats please thank
them for their generosity hosting us
here
[Applause]
we had a number of historic firsts in
this event one being the prize fund 325
thousand dollars the largest prize fund
in the history of the sink field cup and
also the largest prize fund in the world
for this sort of event that could only
happen through the generosity of dr
jeannie and rex singfield who has
who have not only
donated to this event but to many others
that happen here in st louis
and
all around the united states as they
have influenced chess here in this
country please give them a warm hand
without great leadership this doesn't
happen we want to thank the brainchild
of the grand chester gary kasparov who i
believe is in greece right now may be
watching
michael karakovsky who is the executive
director of the grand chess tour tony
rich who's the executive director of the
chess club and joy bray
who
no title i could say would suffice
she's just the head lady in charge thank
them please for all that they do
[Applause]
we had great sponsors uh super bet in
romania vivendi in france chess club e4
in zagreb and of course the st louis
chess club
without their money frankly and also
their determination their organizational
skills this could not have happened in a
trying year as this one was for all of
us please give the sponsors a big hand
and they'll be coming back next year as
well
[Applause]
and to continue the proceedings i'll
turn it over to executive director of
the chess club tony rich
thank you maurice
and thank you all for joining us here
tonight i can't tell you it's uh it's a
bittersweet moment for me the st louis
rapid and blitz and sing field cup
typically wrap up our summer of chess
and it's usually hectic and crazy and
we're just catching our breath
but you know this time around i have to
say i'm going to miss all the players
it's been exciting chess it's been
wonderful to watch you fight across the
board um especially since covet has
prevented us from doing that really now
for almost two years so thank you all
for making this such a memorable event
for for me and for all of your chess
fans around the world i just want to
reiterate something by the way you guys
probably don't know this but since its
inception since the chess club launched
and thanks to the generosity of dr
jeannie and rex singfield we've been
able to award more than 10 million
dollars in prize money
right 10 million in prize money for
tournaments across the years of the
chess club
[Applause]
it just goes to show that chess really
has blossomed and changed in america for
way in ways that that will never go back
you know we will always continue to
progress and see the great things that
are that are to come
so rex thank you you know personally for
for making all of that possible
it is now my pleasure to introduce to
you uh the man of the hour the one whose
namesake uh we have for this tournament
who founded the chess club now more than
13 years ago and who continues to be a
great inspiration and driver for the st
louis chess club rex infield
[Applause]
thank you tony
you know
the bard
uh the bard is william shakespeare
the bard was right parting is such sweet
sorrow
and it's always true we feel it all the
time but we have to go through it each
time so i want to thank all the players
for an outstanding performance this year
and with all the decisive games there
was a lot of exciting chats
congratulations to all of you for making
the tour entertaining and successful
despite all of the coveted and travel
restrictions
as we wrap up the 2021 season and say
goodbye to players for now we look
forward to 2022 with an expanded
schedule
i would like to thank gary kasparov for
his vision support and direction for the
grand chess tour
as i mentioned at the opening ceremony
we conditioned two new trophies
commissioned two new trophies for the
saint louis rapid and blitz and the
sinkfield cup that were custom-made by
timpani the winners will be receiving
smaller replica versions soon
it has been an honor having all of you
here in st louis and working with
joy and all of her crew and shannon and
all of her crew they've done an amazing
job
better than all the rest of us put
together i might add
isn't that true let's have a hand for
joy and shannon
[Applause]
and kevin
and the guy out front
so
so it's been really been an honor having
all of you here and
actually you're welcome to stay
so let's give the players a big round of
applause of thanks
[Applause]
thank you rex
so i mentioned that there's a series of
historic firsts for this tournament
first for the prize money there's also
the fact that the singfield cup
decided for the first time
the winner of the grand chess tour
overall
the points accrued here was what made
the champion the champion for the grand
chess tour it was also the first time
that a player won the sink field cup
twice
clear first other players had won
once and then tied for first but this
player the winner of the event
did it twice by himself
and another historic first
is the fact that my commentators
co-commentators alejandro ramirez yasser
sirwan and i
actually agreed on something
and that was the brilliancy prize there
was a brilliant surprise awarded for
this tournament by brian priester of key
west florida brian is here brian if you
don't mind standing acknowledging your
generosity thank you so much for that
and brian wanted to see fighting chess
he wanted to encourage the players to go
at it throw as many pawns and pieces at
each other as possible and come up with
some amazing games and one player there
were a couple of amazing games and the
players lobbied hard when they came down
to their interview to see whether or not
they would be the ones chosen
and i think one stood above the rest in
not only his playing skills but his
political skills as well no we were not
unduly influenced his play was
absolutely fantastic this particular
game was brilliant it featured
just a few amazing moves one queen
retreat that we will not forget anytime
soon the winner of the first brilliancy
prize ever awarded for the sing phil cup
for his victory against the eventual
winner of the tournament maxine vashi
lagrave please give a hand to
grandmaster lanier dominguez
congratulations
[Applause]
and
the three players
who fought hard and had incredible
results
at this event a tied for a second
place they got here different ways two
of them
won two games and drew the rest another
actually lost one game but showed his
incredible fighting spirit and came back
to have
victories that put him to that moment as
well that second place finish
there were three american players as a
matter of fact so congratulations for
second place
wesley so fabiano caruana and the lanier
dominguez
[Applause]
however to the victor goes to spoils and
one player played incredible chess
and i have to say
this is another historic first
no one has ever won the sinkfield cup
after losing a game in the tournament
ever this previous seven editions
the winner was not blemished once
but in this tournament
a player lost earlier in the event we
thought is he going to be able to do it
we said are you going to be able to come
back he said wait until the very end and
then yesterday he said to me now you can
call it a comeback
the winner of the 2021 singfield cup
from france maxine vashielagrov
[Applause]
tony and rex if you don't mind taking a
photo with the championship trophy with
the champion this is indeed his second
championship he won back
in 2017.
i'm right about that 2017.
as i said he did lose a game
but he bounced back with a couple of
victories not easy to do in a tournament
of this level
four wins more wins than anyone in the
tournament one loss
a amazing performance despite losing the
brilliancy prize
a game he himself played some brilliant
games powerful chess
and is the deserving winner
allele blue indeed
great job
[Applause]
he had the exact same score as last time
plus three
to win the event six out of nine he
didn't have to win the last round this
time though last time he he had to win
the last round to clear to take clear
first
so congratulations maxine for that maxim
takes home a first place check of 90 000
which a little birdie has told me will
be a hundred thousand dollars next year
and by little birdie i mean rex infield
so
that's
that's as good as anybody right there
maxine there was another prize at work
at this event as well and that was the
title of grand chess tour champion
and there were three prizes for that
100 000 50 000 and 25 000.
taking third place after winning the
first
event of the year
in bucharest he wasn't able to keep up
that fine form but nevertheless had
enough points to secure that place
in history
third place for the grand chess tour
this year
chakriar mahmoud
i should mention also from azerbaijan
azerbaijani superstar one of the best
players in the world of course
second place
went to this man you already have heard
his name
he
finished tied for dead last okay i guess
it's not dead last it's tied for last
tournament of the year you do that
that's usually just a write-off like you
got no chance
but he showed some comeback skills in
the next tournament in
his hometown of paris which he did not
win
but he came in high place and then
again came back this is like the
comeback tour again came back in the on
the very last day in zagreb
after four days he was trailing but he
came back on the fifth day and showed
his incredible blitz skills and one
zagreb and then he comes here
and wins the thing
pretty remarkable that only took second
place it wasn't for that
poor finish of the poor finish at the
beginning he would have certainly come
in first but nevertheless
fifty thousand dollars richer and in
second place from france maxim vashila
grave
[Applause]
now to imagine somebody performed better
than that is pretty remarkable by itself
but consistency
pays off
uh this
gentleman in this first tournament of
the year place i think it was fifth
fourth
high just put it top half then he went
on to paris and won the event
then he went then he came here in saint
louis also finished in the top half
in the saint louis rapid and blitz and
in the sink field cup he had a
remarkable finish of tying for second
place that was enough to secure him the
grand chest
and
thousand dollars bringing his total
prize money
to 142
500.
four tournaments
that's
well at least that's what tony said
that's a lot of bang for the buck right
there that's the money he's buying
dinner right here that's what i heard
the winner of the 2021 grand chess tour
from the united states grand master
wesley soh
rex and tony please if you don't mind
taking some photos with the champion
only one other player in history has won
two grand chess tour titles
one of them is a pretty decent player
his name is magnus
carlson wesley becomes only the second
player on tour to win
not an easy thing to do
and wesley managed to pull it off yet
again
with wesley for showing that he belongs
always at the top of the circuit will
always be a threat
and he's actually been playing great
chess all year long so
once again
[Applause]
wesley
start with you maxine would you like to
say a few words
for winning the cup
i'll try to keep it short
but first of all
of course a huge thank you to virginia
and waxing field for their continuous
support and
once again uh
being the main
guys behind this uh great tournament and
great events we just had in saint louis
and we will have some more
and thank you to
everyone at the chess club
as a hall of fame
you know for helping
organizing smoothly it's not easy in
this period but i must say everything
was running
extremely well i mean
you know with all those restrictions i
had to to come to the us
quite early i have to say
it's been a while since i've been home
but uh
or you know
you know a really fun event and
yeah still serious of course
in terms of preparation but
just a great event to to take part of as
always
um thank you to
all the arbiters all the players for you
know for the tournament running smoothly
and for the fighting games
and uh of course congratulations to
wesley so for
for winnings uh the grand chester that
was impressive
and uh
of course uh like it would take too long
to to thank them all but uh of course i
have many people to thank
uh for their continuous you know support
to me for
you know to my friends to my family and
to all the people you know from etienne
of course was my
my main coach but my wool team
who makes a lot of efforts
to
you know
make
make me
the person i am and help me as a chess
player and as a person to
to play my my best chess it was not easy
this year for me and
you know these last few months have been
a breakthrough again for me so that was
really nice and
i cannot help but but mention as well uh
one of my former trainer nicolas
piudenov who passed away this year so
that victory will be for him
thank you
[Applause]
and wesley would you like to come up and
say a few words please as the grand
chess tour winner
well thank you very much
uh i just want to thank uh the grand
chester for having this event
uh also the saint louis chess club
and especially uh rex and genie
thingfield for
without without whom of which i wouldn't
be a chess professional
uh so thank you rex for making american
chess great again
and uh
also i'd like to thank the the uscf
usgs uh chris byrd
uh who's official
and also the arbiters for working so
hard for this tournament
and i just like to thank all the people
who made this event possible
grand chester
this year has been very difficult
some of the players haven't been able to
come
but st louis is really determined to do
to do things and finish things once they
have decided to do it
and
i'd like to congratulate maxim for
winning the thingfield cup
having four wins and also playing the
best chess
and uh
yeah i think i think american chess is
the best in the world uh there's a large
chess boom the last few years
mainly thanks to st louis
so
uh if maxim ever wants to switch i
believe there's still
there there's still one spot i think
left
but he better decide soon before
because american chess is uh is the hub
of
the professional chess world
and also i'd like to to thank my mother
uh for all her hard work
and uh it's it's good to be back here in
st louis i haven't been here in two
years and it's very good to see familiar
faces
such as joy bray and tony rich always
good to see a friendly face
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you wesley
i would like to echo that
the world doesn't seem like the same
place if there's not chess in st louis
and the fact that we were
able to come here
and watch these great players
show
why and how they work so hard
to play at this elite level and create
games that will live
for all time in some cases
memorable
incidents that occur just
it's just an extraordinary place and
it's been magical yasser and alejandro
and and now we have so much fun
downstairs you have no idea when we're
doing commentary
and we are really often in shock given
what chess was like 15 20 years ago in
the united states and trying to compare
it to now
night and day night and day it has been
transformative
what has happened to chess thanks to the
magic that is saint louis
and it will continue
the next event will be
ultimate moves
that will take place on september 7th
and then we will have
uh our chess 9lx chess 960 or fischer
random i think one gary kasparov is
showing up for that yeah i heard right
so we'll have that and then of course
the huge event our national
championships
the u.s championship the u.s women's
championship as well in october so it
doesn't end
the work the hard work continues but the
fun continues it's why we play the game
chess has regaled us since we were young
and it continues to be evergreen to this
day so thank you so much for joining our
closing ceremony don't forget to come
see us again in a little over a week's
time and everybody out there thank you
so much
good night
[Music]
[Music]
you
you